[Musique]
la FRCA le département de La Réunion le
syndicat du sucre de la Réunion vous
présente terre
[Musique]
d'ici comme chaque matin marieance
paillette commence sa journée avec ses
lapins dès son entrée dans le bâtiment
d'levag elle s'assure que les mères
allitent bien leur
petits très important parce que tê une
fois par jour
[Musique]
es ont 8 jours aujourd'hui là iles ont
faim donc bouge le
en la Meur va rester combien de temps à
l'été là 5 minutes 5 minutes et les
petits on le ventre plein après quelques
minutes plus tard les laperau sont un
effet repu et rassasiés pour la
journée ça le renouvellement métropole
don
ventre plein bien gonflé ouais bien
plein et prochaine tté sera pour demain
matin c'est en 2005 que marieance se
lance dans la production cunicole
l'élevage de lapinésente alors pour elle
un choix judicieux de diversifier les
revenus de l'exploitation agricole
familiale c'était pour pouvoir
diversifier expitation par que moi
j'étaisis que de la CAN et la CAN c'est
un
revenu fixe à l'année et donc comme le
lapin c'est un revenu régulier même si
pas beaucoup mais au moin c'est régulier
c'est pour ça qu'on fait ça grâce à ses
compétences et à son savoir-faire
marifance devient alors éleveuse
multiplicatrice un maillon essentiel de
toute la filière et pour tous les
éleveurs de la CPLR la coopérative des
producteurs de lapin de la réunion au
départ c'était prévu d'être un éleveur
tout simple et comme il manquait de un
élevage multiplication donc on m'a
proposé cette opportunité là de devenir
un multiplicateur on doit respecter de
regarder des bonnes femelles pour les
éleveurs les futurs éleveurs qui vont
avoir ces femelles là pour reproduire
chez eux ça permet à la filière de
livrer aux éleveurs des animaux ça après
les lapins mariffrance s'occupe des
beauins avec comme tous les matins
distribution des rations d'aliments et
de
foin c'est passionnant a le BF mais
c'est plus dur c'est plus un animal plus
costaud membre de l'fdar l'association
féminine pour le développement agricole
réunionné mariefance peut aussi compter
sur la solidarité de ses collègues
agricultrices pour avancer dans ses
projets je trouve très bien d'avoir fait
de faire partie de cette association là
de femcultrice parce que on découvre le
travail des autres on voir autre chose
que le nôtre cette association là va
permet aux femmes arcultrices et aux
conjointes mais de se réunir quelquefois
pour discuter de leur problèm
de de beaucoup de choses de la vie de
s'entraider entre nous et de voir
réellement ben ce qui se passe chez les
autres on fait les formations ben pour
pouvoir ben avoir des des connaissances
sur autres choses que sur le NRE on peut
en relier bah le côté travail et
convivial
[Musique]
ensemble jeune agricultrice luciniaab
s'est lancée par la force des choses
dans la production végétale avec Armand
son mari le couple est aujourd'hui
installé dans les EAU de Saint-Paul où
il cultive cette terre fertile je me
suis installé en 2010 et le maréchage à
la base on faisait du géranium
et vu que enfin c'était pas viable
financièrement donc on a arrêté et on a
mis de la canne et du maréchage depuis
on va dire 2011 12 et d'autant plus que
que ce soit mon mari ou moi on était
plutôt formé pour faire de l'élevage
mais comme en fait dans le monde
agricole c'est pas c'est pas évident et
en fait du coup on était obligé de se
retourner vers le maréchage vu la
surface qu'on avait c'était trop petit
sur ces 3000 m Carr de maréchage lucinia
produit plusieurs sortes de légumes des
breides du chou mais aussi diverses
variétés de salad ben là c'est de la
batavia blanche etol
et sinon on fait aussi de la laiture
feuille de chaîne
rouge feuille de chaîne verte voilà en
parti pour ce qu'on fait en salade donc
un peu de tout sur une petite parcelle
finalement voà oui on est obligé de
faire avec voilà comme la parcelle elle
est petite donc on réduit le tout un
maximum pour pouvoir
produire avec un emploi du temps déjà
bien rempli lucinia a rejoint récemment
lav d'Ar l'association féminine pour le
développement agricole réunionnaé dont
elle est aujourd'hui présidente
l'objectif de l'association en fait
c'est de d'essayer de regrouper toutes
les agricultrices de l'île qui qui
travaillent afin de faire des échanges
de voir les autres exploitations de nous
ouvrir vers euh vers les autres et en
faisant des sorties des formations on a
un voyage prévu en métropole l'année
prochaine pour découvrir d'autres
exploitations et aussi nous former pour
euh aller vers la diversification de nos
exploitations créé en novembre 2013
l'avdar compte à ce jour une quinzaine
d'adhérentes des agricultrices chefs
d'exploitation et fi de l'être on
s'aperçoit assez souvent que les
agricultriceses sont pas assez mises en
valeur sur leur exploitation elles sont
plus vues en tant que épouse ou compagne
et non pas en tant
queagricultrice même donc du coup l'idée
c'est ben de faire voir que les
agricultes elles sont là elles sont
présentes elles travaillent tous les
jours comme leur mari et que voilà on on
revendique notre place d'agricultrice en
fait tout ce qui dit formation que ce
soit en anglais que ce soit pour tout ce
qui dit touristique et tout la la FDSEA
est là il nous aide dans nos formations
oui l'association est à les portes grand
ouvertes toutes les agricultrices ils
sont les bienvenus et ben on vous
[Rires]
attend
[Musique]